c'est la révélation de la danse
française mais jusque là il était peu
connu dans son propre pays il s'appelle
benjamin millepied il a 29 ans il
triomphe aux états unis comme danseur
étoile
le voici en france comme chorégraphe
cette fois pour plusieurs
représentations à l'opéra de paris
sophie jouve jean-marie nos quartiers ce
jeune français qui dansent à new york
est une star là bas mais quasiment
inconnu chez nous pas pour longtemps
danseur étoile du new york city ballet
il entre par la grande porte à l'opéra
de paris
le voici chorégraphe d'une des troupes
les plus prestigieuses au monde
à 28 ans ça va 25 j'en ai fait quand
j'étais petit je pense que c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut commencer tôt c'est un
désir qu'on a un vrai désir c'est un
métier c'est quelque chose qu'ils
m'entendent discipline la danse
un ballet pour vingt danseurs deux
étoiles et le choeur accentue ce
millepied ne se refuse rien
pour cette parabole sur l'amour
oh
une danse virtuose est classique avec
une énergie contemporaine il ya une
espèce de facilités de langage qui est
évidente tout de suite parce que c'est
nous connaît et sait de quoi il parle et
c'est ce qu'on vit puisqu'il veut la
même chose à new york
on sent que que c'est un danseur qui a
cette jubilation d'utiliser son corps
c'est les mouvements et le vocabulaire
de lens une sorte de retour au bercail
pour benjamin millepied qui dirige on le
voit les étoiles française avec passion
et naturel
quand
après sa première chorégraphie à l'opéra
on attend désormais qu'il montre à paris
ses talents de danseur
benjamin millepied un nom prédestiné
la suite des prix